here is Muppet man Chris Hayes he's very
very upset because here in Florida we
are not going to allow for genital
mutilation of children and this is very
upsetting to this human Muppet enjoy
now the sick irony here the one that I
just can't get over and really kind of
sticks with me
is that the right wing movement that
gave us this new law signed yesterday is
the very same group of people that
screamed about parental rights for years
amidst the pandemic I get to say whether
my kid wears a mask I get to say whether
my kid gets vaccinated I get to say
whether my kid goes to school
and Ron DeSantis was the public face of
that movement
that very same wing of the Republican
Party embodied by Ron DeSantis and the
government of the State of Florida
has now demanded and produced a
situation in which the government that
guy you saw there with the tough guy
Swagger about freedom is going to decide
if your child
who lives in your home
that you gave birth to or raised that
you love your kid what kind of care they
can get
he decides
care that to be clear the American
Academy of Pediatrics supports and
recommends
think about what this means that is what
the courage to be free means
Freedom means that in my household our
family decides what kind of Health Care
our child does or does not get
not Ron DeSantis not the Republican
party oh Muppet man let me clean this up
for you first off you and everyone that
watches MSNBC and all your network
cohorts and the entire Democrat Party
basically were four mandates you were
four kids being forced to be injected
with things whether it was with their
parents permission or not that's number
one so you're you're a complete
hypocrite but I get that hypocrisy is
dead in 2023. the other part of this is
we are talking about mutilating
children's genitals destroying their
god-given body okay and we know that
there is a social contagion element to
this meaning that suddenly it's not as
if suddenly out of nowhere that we get
all of these mostly girls that want to
transition to be boys there is a social
component it has something to do with
Tick Tock and the internet and social
pressures and all of these things now we
had a debate uh before we did the show
today because there was a picture of a
girl biological girl
who posted what her post-op meaning
post-trans surgery looks like and we had
a debate whether we were going to post
the picture and ultimately we decided
not to because it is so profoundly
upsetting and disturbing and everything
else that we didn't want to put up we
also thought that YouTube might just
take down the stream altogether and give
the channel a strike so we did not put
it up but if you want to see what it
looks like when when a young girl a 15
year old girl gets the surgery what they
literally do is they take muscle tissue
and skin and they take that from her
thigh to create I mean this is just so
unbelievably awful to then create a
penis that is not a penis it does not
look like a penis it does not function
like a penis it has no sexual utility or
anything else if you want to see the
image that's going around the internet
right now Ashley Sinclair who I've had
on the show once or twice says she did
tweet it she put it up with a warning so
you actually have to click through the
warning to see it it's at Saint Claire
Ashley
s-t-c-l-a-i-r-a-s-h-l-e-y at Sinclair
Ashley if you want to see that image we
just decided not to put it up but that
these people are so for this is so
insane
[Music]